[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de page
sur tv 78 et radio sensations et ça
tombe bien parce que nous allons
justement parlé dans cette émission pas
mal de la radio dont vous savez qu'on
fait appeler les 100 ans de la première
émission depuis la tour eiffel puis les
40 ans des radios libres
et puis nous parlerons un petit peu
aussi politique globale rostit de paris
saclay qui est la première université en
mathématiques et pour aborder tous ces
sujets balle
les stéphanois sont bonjour bonjour cher
patrice bonjour à tous je vous
accueillons premier d'abord parce que je
vous salue avec tous les honneurs
mérités et puis chef vous êtes vous êtes
en vision alors que tout le monde est
maintenant plateau c'est comme s'il se
passait quelque chose je ne sais pas
avec ceux ci nous en parlerons de mai 68
il était en train de lancer des pavés
alors aussi guillerot bonjour je suis
ravi de vous accueillir vous donc le
directeur de radio sensations radio
sensations et des cons sont sacrées
sensations un peu plus récemment mais
lens est ses 83 83 89 m dans 83 mjc mais
voilà et c'était c'était donc la
libération des ondes du par exactement
la gauche en 180 laurent mazaury bonjour
bonjour vous êtes maire à toi des noms
courts vice-président de 50 ans et
président de télé 78 donc honneur non
des représentants la du média c'est
rigole fortia des animateurs de radios
libres en 1981 sur radio scoop de france
à paris qui émettait depuis le sous sol
d'une église
devant célèbre à l'époque il s'affaissa
nicolas du chardonnet faire donner
chardonnay jordan reste parce que j'aime
la beauté c'est un coup après c'est le
20 mai c'est le niveau d'où vous êtes
éditeur toujours toujours
et voilà le dernier la dernière
apparition pour quelques millions ces
deux cas le pineau alors qu'on avait eu
la chance d'avoir dans un ajustement
voilà qui vit des règles de banque qui
passe aussi six mois de l'année en
thaïlande des six mois de l'année en
france et là comme il oblige il passé si
vous en espagne et six mois en france il
vient d'arriver en france
on avait parlé avec lui du covin et
savoir comment ça se passe et des pays
ça se passe assez mal en thaïlande alors
on va commencer pas peut-être cette
bonne nouvelle avant d'aborder les
sujets c'est paris saclay qui est à la
foule en ondes la fois j'ai pas ne pas
la foi mais à nouveau plu tout premier
premier mondial dans le classement de
shanghai pour les mathématiques
c'est extraordinaire comme nous c'est
extraordinaire c'est un classement qui
est très complexe dans laquelle les
critères sont très strictes et puis ça
rend vraiment grasset et tout le mérite
qu'elle cette université de paris saclay
c'est vrai que là aujourd'hui elle est
primé sur les mathématiques mais c'est
un des secteurs dans lequel elle excelle
c'est une vraie volonté d'avoir sur le
plateau de saclay à saint quentin en
yvelines un univers d'excellence à la
fois pour la pratique de nouvelles
technologies puisque c'est quand même
essentiellement sur l'orientation mais
également d'avoir su fédérer sur ce
plateau à l'initiative d'ailleurs à
l'époque de madame pécresse qui était
ministre des universités d'avoir su
fédérer sur ce plateau tous que la les
matières grises peuvent coûter en france
et d'être un petit peu aujourd'hui la
silicon valley à la française
d'un point de vue déjà public mais
également parapublic et d'y associer des
entreprises privées et non des moindres
donc c'est une très belle réussite c'est
à mon avis une première reconnaissance
je suis certain que leur ado dans les
années à venir et puis bien évidemment
c'est un bassin très générateur
d'emplois à part ça c'est materis on
n'est pas que dans la réflexion n'est
aussi dans l'opéra tiff
donc je crois que c'est vrai
salué pour le brio de centralisation de
chercheurs de souligner c'est à la fois
l'université east la fois leurs
recherches et le lien entre justement
l'université les entreprises
savreux jaillit évidemment sur
l'ensemble du territoire et c'est en
cela que je compare la silicon valley
avec des entreprises par contre qu'ils
sont on va dire déjà de les installer un
qui ont de grosses capelette
investissements mais qui savent à
travers la recherche la transcrire ce
qu'on appelle la recherche appliquée au
bénéfice de tous et je pense que c'est
une très très belle réussite et c'est
vrai que les mathématiques ça ne parle
pas à tout le monde
néanmoins je rappelle que c'est en amont
de toute décision et de tout progrès
scientifique et entre autres en amont de
tout les progrès liés aux nouvelles
technologies
ça parle surtout pas nos collégiens qui
sont nullissimes quoi d'après tous les
classements pisa 5 est curieux c'est
cette excellence des chercheurs et cette
nullité apparente d'aider des jeunes
classes quoi ça c'est les même troublant
beaucoup de mathématiciens prix mais
surperforme à partir d'un certain âge
mais là on se demande comment on va
surperformer dans vingt ans parce que
fut vu les classements actuels c'est pas
terrible
c'est la raison même temps on a une
grosse progression du nombre
d'ingénieurs en france par étudier sur
50 ha mais c'est bien qu'un décalage
entre on va dire la la masse globale est
effectivement la crème qui effectivement
brille au niveau international mais
soyons optimistes que vraiment le
pourcentage des enfants des jeunes
volontaires aller vers une métier
d'agent progresse donc voilà
et en plus ces décès comme un peu d
exception les grands mathématiciens je
me souviens de de l'ancien patro de la
sorbonne qui était mathématicien
lui-même qui était normal liens etc et
qui disait mais moi j'ai vite compris je
ne serai jamais un grand mathématicien
donc c'était donc c'est un niveau quand
même exceptionnel
francis là dessus vous avez vos
commentaires en tout cas sur les écoles
de journalisme
oui on voit le niveau baisser depuis
hier déjà quelques années oui ça c'est
vrai sur les étagères et on voit la
culture générale et puis surtout
internet un peut tout changer
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui un
journaliste où il coupé internet c'est
fini
dans les écoles on a déjà fait
l'expérience on le retrouve internet
débrouillez vous pour trouver vos
sources et malheureusement c'est plus
compliqué à l'arrêt donc c'est souvent
la référence c'est wikipédia c'est mais
c'est un peu le problème il faut faire
attention à ce qu'il y ait des erreurs
stéphane minson on avait déjà parlé
justement de cette excellence de paris
saclay en matière de mathématiques qui
vous disent ils finalement c'est pas
tellement étonnant parce que pour faire
des mathématiques faut pas beaucoup de
moyens faux stylo papier robot est
peut-être un petit ordinateur on est
moins bons dans les dents les dans les
sciences où il faut plus
d'investissements ce que j'allais vous
dire patrice 7,7 ce classement n'est pas
n'est pas du tout une surprise puisque
le paris saclay numéro un mondial en
mathématiques
alors c'est une réédition c'était déjà
le cas l'an dernier mais bien avant
l'existence du classement de shanghai il
était de notoriété scientifique mondiale
que paris sud
à l'époque c'était le nom de paris
saclay est l une des toutes premières
universités foire la première université
mondiale
j'ajoute que paris saclay toujours dans
ce classement de shanghai
alors qui obéit à des critères qui lui
sont ce qu'ils sont et ça n'est pas le
seul classement mondial occupe
aujourd'hui toutes disciplines
confondues la 14e place mondiale 1 parmi
parmi des milliers d'université alors
oui c'est vrai que il ya deux
observations sur le fait que ce soit
qu'il s'agisse des mathématiques la
première c'est qu'il s'agit plutôt d'une
recherche fondamentale même si il ya
toute une
une pandémie thématiques qui sont plutôt
des mathématiques appliquées mais là il
s'agit plutôt de recherche fondamentale
et sa montre laurent mazuray a raison de
le souligner ça montre l'importance de
la recherche fondamentale qui n'est pas
toujours très bien comprise de la part
des politiques et des décideurs publics
en général parce qu en recherche
fondamentale en général on trouve ce
qu'on ne cherche pas ça s'appelle la
sérendipité
et donc c'est assez assez difficilement
vendables sur le plan
le plan budgétaire et sur le plan
politique et puis d'autre part c'est
vrai vous le rappeliez faire de la
recherche en mathématiques ça coûte ça
coûte pas grand chose ça coûte rien il
faut ils font une craie ou un stylo et
un tableau et puis il faut d esprit très
bien formés ça ça coûte un peu plus cher
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'appareillage techniques technologiques
qui est indispensable dans d'autres
champs disciplinaires je pense en
matière de recherche atmosphérique en en
physique en chimie en informatique etc
alors j mee cela dit et ça c'était pas
mal classés c'est la 49e place et allié
aussi d'autres placements il ya
l'agriculture il ya la médecine très
bien placé enfin donc il ya évidemment
des subsides plutôt scientifique dans
les caisses alors c'est vrai que ce
classement de shanghai on pourrait
entrer dans les détails et et critiquer
un petit peu la façon dont il est doté
des faits mais bon j'ai vu enfin c'est
un classement c'est un classement parmi
d'autres c'est le plus connu parce que
c'est parmi les plus le parmi les plus
anciens mais c'est si vous voulez
surtout du c'est un vaste débat mais
c'est surtout du quantitatif le
classement de shanghai 1 cc c'est un
classement au poids au poids des
publications au poids des références au
poids des distinctions le paris paris
saclay paris sud ont un à un volume de
médailles fields le nobel des
mathématiques tout à fait tout à fait
impressionnant et évidemment ça pèse
très lourdement dans ce dans ce
classement c'est vrai que oui c'est vrai
que la france a un grand nombre de
médailles fields notamment le plus connu
étant cédric villani qui a fait
engueuler et qui est réputé depuis
depuis des décennies
bien classé non mais c'est pas casser
non non mais il a raison de rappeler sur
quels critères et sur quels critères
et donc c'est une voilà enfin en tout
cas c'est une excellente nouvelle
championne faceo premier thème de cette
émission va souhaiter bon anniversaire à
la radio alors c'est vrai qu'on fait les
100 ans alors de la première diffusion
de la tour eiffel
je sais pas pourquoi on a avancé
beaucoup les choses parce que c'était en
été je crois le 11 septembre 2009 121 tu
es pressé de faire cet anniversaire et
la loi on va parler aussi de la loi sur
les radios libres je crois que c'est
nous vendre un donc je mets mes cm 80
pour la libéralisation des radios libres
voilà c'est ça je pense que la date
importante
et puis et puis la tour eiffel doit
pratiquer dans son existence au fric qui
la radio parce que l'été flèche pourrait
être supprimée puisqu'elle avait été
fait pour lui
pour l'exposition universelle devait
disparaître elle est restée grâce à la
radio alors c'est vrai que quand on
regarde l'histoire de la radio basse et
d'histoire quand même non ce qui nous
frappe d'abord c'est les grands moments
quoi alors quelle histoire mais je
voudrais revenir sur la précédente
intervention c'est aussi l'aspect
technologique et scientifique qui met
cette ce média à disposition
effectivement de l'homme parce qu'il
faut déjà avoir l'idée de créer le
mécanisme de la radio après il est
important de voir aussi que quelque part
la france est directement liée par ce
qu'est la tour eiffel certes mais aussi
le fait que c'est en france que c'est un
lieu et que ça se passe et que cette
première édition permet effectivement de
briller du coup dans l'univers des
médias au niveau international pour la
france je pense que c'est un point qu'on
doit de sauver et après bien sûr il ya
le contenu est là peut-être que notre
collègue on puisse avoir parlé vous
surtout la radio c'est le premier média
de masse instantanée puisqu'il faut se
rappeler qu'avant c'était que la presse
des journaux donc c'était tous les jours
mais là la radio ne permet tait
instantanément de pouvoir voilà de
donner de l'information à tous les tous
les possesseurs de postes même si au
début c'était évidemment très courant
mais voilà ça a été le premier média de
masse la radio qui a relié les français
les gens entre eux est-ce que la wilaya
la presse écrite qui ne marchait très
bien belle et la radio au fond mais
quand est-ce que ça commence à être un
média alors vous dites c'est un média
populaire mais quand est-ce qu'on est
d'aider des moyens d'écouter la radio
assez vite assez vite mais je pense que
c'est après guerre aussi que ça
commençait vraiment à prendre prendre
forme
la guerre a
notamment l'appel du général de gaulle
c'est un peu ce qui a popularisé aussi
toujours dit andré 18 juin écoutez c'est
à populariser la région en tant que tel
voilà pour pour se dire mais il faut
investir dans des postes de radio des
postes de radio sont devenus beaucoup
plus populaire à l'époque comme les
messages radio à l'ensemble département
mais aussi il ya donc ça c'est quand
même il ya l'utilisation pendant toute
la guerre qu'importe français parlent
aux français aux ordinateurs et de
l'autre côté il y avait aussi la radio
pétainiste et collaboratrices et radio
paris ment radio paris nantes paris et
allemands mais on voit d'ailleurs
l'intérêt tout de suite que des
politiques se ruent et quand je dis des
politiques en l'occurrence de l'occupant
qui tout de suite saisi effectivement
des médias en se disant après tout il ya
peut-être du monde à l'écouté et on doit
le contrôler et de fait effectivement
les tout de suite les alliés s'en
servent également à la fois comme un
média de propagande la bêta de
communication quasiment technique
je passe effectivement des messages à la
radio tout cas immédiatement le côté
mass médias que que vous sauviez est
pris en compte par à la fois les
résidents les deux côtés on est quelque
part
malgré les situations dramatiques ça
donne aussi ses lettres de noblesse et
de l'efficacité du média radio
et oui c est ça donne d'ailleurs le fait
de dire qu'on ne voit pas le disent
alors on parlera peut-être après avec la
télévision ça donne aussi une dimension
nouvelle c'est vrai stéphane mans son
club politique de l'histoire liste de la
radio c'est un peu de l'histoire pour
nous aussi d'une certaine ascèse une
histoire bien sûr cette histoire et vous
savez pour pour relier cela a au premier
sujet que notamment à lui vs q nous
avons un centre de recherche extrêmement
important sur sur l'histoire culturelle
qui
a pour objet de recherche notamment
l'histoire de l'audiovisuel et
l'histoire de ce média particulier
qu'est la radio c'est un à la fois un
objet d'histoire et c'est un instrument
qui qui permettent aussi d'approcher
d'autres objets avec notamment la
question des archives radiophoniques qui
qui sont qui sont aujourd'hui l'objet
d'une véritable exploration scientifique
indigne de ce nom et c'est vrai alors
politiquement eu lieu route veulent
qu'ils aient cessé ses causeries au coin
du feu il ya malaise france qui était le
premier je crois le premier président du
conseil on n'est pas contre hyper
premier ministre à faire ça et puis
après arrive quand même la télévion de
gaulle les premiers les grands les
grands d'intervention et au début on
d'ailleurs on disait qu'ils maîtrisaient
pas trop la télévision donc il prend des
cours avec avec un sociétaire de la
comédie française
il vérifie ses discours la télévision
mais quand il ya des moments dramatiques
et je pense à mai 68 et son discours où
il va essayer de reprendre les choses en
main
c'était la radio on en écoute un extrait
françaises français étant le détenteur
de la légitimité nationale et
républicaine
j'ai envisagé depuis 24 heures toutes
les éventualités sans exception qui me
permettrait de maintenir
j'ai pris mes résolutions dans les
circonstances présentes je ne me
retirerai pas intéressant parce que au
fond c'est comme ça qui reprend la main
il y aura cette manifestation c'est des
événements vont se retourner et que vous
expliquer qu'il ait choisi plutôt la
radio la télévision justement mais c'est
aussi parce que c'était la radio c'était
d'immédiateté absolue dont parlait
monsieur tout à l'heure c'est clair que
même les manifestants étaient au courant
immédiatement les hanter les gens
d'europe 1 à l'époque était quand même
très actif ve et oui il ya un barrage la
bayadh et c'est vrai que c'est la
naissance d'europe 1
moins de 20 t elle parce que transiter
sur le terrain alors que les radios
nationales étaient un peu laissé chris
était cette intrusion de la radio donc
je pense que le général de gaulle avait
bien compris que comme tout le monde se
mettait à écouter ça c'était merveilleux
et qui toucherait aussi cette population
de d'étudiants meyer est pour lui une
facture est pas une dramatisation du
fait qu'il n'y ait pas l'image
moi je crois quand même un ca non
forcément fonctionne et d'imaginaire
tous les tous les avantages de la radio
on en reparlera tout à l'heure avec
l'image aujourd'hui oui ça faisait
travailler l'imaginaire de voilà des
gens étaient très attentifs
enfin aujourd'hui enfin aujourd'hui oui
les familles sont souvent devant leur
poste de télé mais à l'époque les
familles se réunissaient devant le poste
de radio
c'était vraiment la direction au milieu
du salon qui met des jeux dans
l'inconscient même du général de gaulle
n'y a pas ce côté j'ai été pendant la
guerre à la radio je me suis mal exprimé
à la radio donc je reprends ce média qui
m'a fait en fait on va bloquer puis les
critères de baden baden on sait et c'est
donc ne pas se montrer été aussi tu es
aussi d'une certaine façon une face il
ya aussi le taux de pénétration du
nombre d'écrans à l'époque on est en 68
et nombre d'image et de postes de
télévision semaine très vite et moi même
quand j'étais jeune j'avais un poste en
noir et blanc pour changer les chaînes
ont tourné comme ça c'était très
compliqué je me souviens de ma grand
écoutant la radio
oui il fallait quand même des contrées
savait pas s'il allait laisser les
marchés allaient porter à huit jours en
vacances ça marche pas je pense qu'aussi
cette volonté d'efficace le territoire
le fait de choisir la radio stéphane
c'était aussi l'époque l'époque de des
transistors donc des radios miniatures
la radio ça a été pendant longtemps un
meuble très lourd une lolette tsf et
c'est un conte qui trônait au milieu du
salon comme comme aujourd'hui chez
beaucoup de français la télévision
allait mais en 68 on pouvait avec un
petit poste de radio comme on disait
naguère radio à transistor recevoir ce
média à peu près partout dans la voiture
sur la plage dans la rue etc
alors il ya aussi il ya aussi cette ce
paramètre de l'efficacité
bien sûr est ce qu'aujourd'hui on
pourrait imaginer n'hésitez pas
emmanuel macron près un message très
très bram à 10 ans par exemple et se
passer de la télévision j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui on voudrait
pas mais surtout c'est vrai qu'il ya des
médias me voyais des nouveaux médias il
ya l'internet
il ya quand même l'image qua non on peut
difficilement échapper de l'image
aujourd'hui il faut pas oublier
effectivement été réseaux sociaux
n'importe quel citoyen aujourd'hui
devient reporter voilà donc avec son
téléphone instantanément on peut envoyer
sur sur les réseaux sociaux une image
donc on peut difficilement se passer de
se passer de l'image très décrit
aujourd'hui ce que ces images sont
parfois détournés ou mal exploité on
n'en connaît pas forcément la source
donc ça devient un véritable problème
alors que à l'époque à la radio
effectivement il y avait un travail de
comédienne était aussi plus long faut
rappeler qu'à l'époque à la radio on
monte avec des bandes c'était très long
aujourd'hui les iso equiterra donc voilà
enfin les transmissions était très
longue aussi aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'on peut même en radio en télévision
une fois de plus avec un téléphone on
peut faire un reportage quasiment
instantanément
alors qu'à l'époque c'était beaucoup
plus longs ont trouvé faire une liaison
d'un point a à un point b
je vais passer par des systèmes de
faisceaux les satellites n'existait pas
à l'époque
donc c'était beaucoup plus long donc on
fait il y avait une rigueur beaucoup
plus importante je pense mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui un événement qui n'a pas
d'image on al impression qu on veut
systématiquement avoir une image sale
parfois démunis du voyeurisme
c'est vrai des chaînes d'information
font souvent leur audience
dès qu'ils peuvent montrer des images
fortes enfin je me souviens ça m'a
marqué ou pas
il ya quelques années on continue de
l'attentât au bataclan
ces images qui avaient été diffusés de
l'intérieur du bataclan c'était choquant
ça a été diffusée sur les réseaux
sociaux
et ça avait fait des millions de vues
voilà aujourd'hui malheureusement c'est
ça aussi la radio à l'époque
effectivement c'était très différent
le réseau de souligner qu'il ya une
différence entre les réseaux sociaux et
parfois les responsables de télévision
justement ne diffuse pas un certain
nombre d'image qui sont qui sont sur les
réseaux sociaux
mais quand vous dites l'exi mal son oui
parfois elles sont très fortes
mais parfois ça m'a toujours amusé par
exemple que quand il ya on se dit va se
passer quelque chose à l'elysée on
envoie un journaliste devant l'elysée or
il serait beaucoup mieux informés dans
son bureau avec la téléphone et un
ordinateur que devant dans la rue
la poursuite de l'image à tout prix les
figures des télévisions d'information
permanente qu'est ce que l'on voit en
général c'est une jeune fille ou un
jeune homme avec un micro et dans la rue
derrière moi il vient de se passer
on vous voit d'autres de leurs collègues
et puis un véhicule de pompiers il
pourrait très bien être à l'autre bout
de la france à change rien mais je pense
que je peux faire pour une publicité
pour paris match fait tout est dit dans
le vieux slogan de paris match
le poids des mots le choc des photos et
donc effectivement les deux doivent
coexister et pourra même politique ou
quelle que soit la personne qui a un
message à faire passer aujourd'hui la
complexité c'est qu'il faut être présent
partout sur tous les supports avec de
l'image avec du texte avec défilement
des photos sur les réseaux sociaux
effectivement il faut même venir faire
venir des youtuber chez soi pour pouvoir
être filmée et faire une roulade
on est obligé d'être partout et celui
qui n'est pas partout mais il a du mal à
exister regardez ce qui s'est plaint que
le président trump a effectivement lui a
coupé l'accès aux réseaux sociaux aux
états unis tout d'un coup évidemment sa
parole ne porte plus est
sauf qu'à l'époque il n'y avait
quasiment que la radio mais pour
continuer ce que vous dites française
guy roux justement on al'impression
alors il y avait des médias et la radio
il y avait la télévision il y avait
internet
tv etc et on a l'impression qu'on arrive
à une sorte de mélange de tous la radio
et le plutôt fine est maintenant tout à
fait même on pratique faisait mon fils
enfin tous les médias se croisent
aujourd'hui humain enfin fond de l'écrit
à travers internet
l'image à travers internet encore c'est
un peu internet qui a un peut regrouper
tous les médias les multi plateformes au
bruit c'est vrai que souvent c'est
encore un débat que j'ai eues la semaine
dernière est ce qu'on doit filmer
absolument tout filmé dans la radio
alors je pense que ce qu'on appelle
radio tout flux les radios musicales
montre un émetteur dans son studio
ouvrir son micro pour des indes est
annoncée à l'isq ça n'a pas d'intérêt
après quand on fait des émissions
politiques comme on en fait avec le tv
78 par exemple ou des magazines avec des
invités là ça un peu plus d'intérêt
effectivement parce que du coup à nos
émissions sont diffusées chez vous et
paf aujourd'hui est diffusée aussi sur
radio sensations
donc voilà je pense qu'il faut de la
mesure tout filmé à tout prix non ça n'a
pas force
ces vannes manceau sur ces voies la
radio une excuse parce que il ya je
crois un surcroît de de liberté pour
celui qui s'exprime sans être filmée et
puis il ya un surcroît d'attention pour
celui qui écoute
j'en suis absolument convaincu je ne ne
suis pas téléspectateurs je ne regarde
pratiquement pas la télévision jeux
j'écoute beaucoup la radio un certain
nombre de deux radios parce que j'ai
l'impression de pouvoir sans doute je
vais pas me concentrer de manière
beaucoup plus simple je suis pas
multitâche manifestement à la radio qu'à
la télévision et je pense que en effet
l'image est bien on la voit plus vite
par rapport à la fois qu'on entend qu'on
entend après même si c'est un un micro
décalage je crois que c'est vraiment
important et c'est ces radios film et
c'est vrai que je trouve ça un peu
dommage
bon je comprends un ce soit perçu comme
étant le le cheminement de qu'une sorte
de dévolution de progrès mais enfin je
moi j'aime bien que les choses soient un
peu plus nettement distingué j'écoute
j'écoute la radio pour l'écouter et pas
pour leurs gardes
c'est amusant parce que c'est là qu'ont
été les stars telles que vous recevez
des actrices disait il faut une
maquilleur le maquis ça devient deuxième
grand moment donc c'est 80 c novembre 80
avec la loi qui permet la libération des
ondes
moi je me souviens effet enquêté un
petit peu avant en 80 dans les 1,80
ministère de l'information même
jacqueline baudrier qui était qui était
le président de radio france à l'époque
et mais pourquoi vous libérez pas les
zones et les réponses officielles c'est
que il ya peu de place c'est parce que
vous voudrez pas
et qu'on peut pas c'était quand même
assez incroyable alors que bond fm était
un monopole de l'état s'il y avait à
part une hésitation que quelques radios
méga l'armée n'y a aucune place
[Rires]
s'étonnant comme des nids quoi déjà c
est non plus c'est pas une erreur des
escarres d'ailleurs ne pas l'avoir fait
il ya une ou deux erreurs comme ça
peut-être qu'il aurait plus comment je
pense qu'il aurait fait s'il avait été
réélu une deuxième fois parce que
c'était dans l'air du temps et en était
un pays pour le coup je voyez pas que je
vois pas comment on peut l'arrêter
et d'ailleurs il y avait avant des
radios libres les tv et radio qui se
cachaient grande majorité des radios
libres par les radios un peu plus
professionnel est à dire les
professionnels sont issus de ces radios
pirates
moi je vous parlais de radio scouts de
france tout à l'heure c'était une radio
pirate aussi bizarre que ça paraisse
d'où la présence dans une cave médaille
parce que si les gens avaient vu dans
quelles conditions que vous à l'époque
je pense que personne ne l'aurait cru
events et une poursuite et j'ai oublié
de l'onda radio mais j'habitais leur 19e
arrondissement on était très opposé de
la place des fêtes il y avait plein
d'émetteurs pirates qui étaient cachées
et toujours la peur du crs qui va surgir
ils ont saisi l'émetteur ici mais il y
en ad'autres de cash et là je pense qui
surgissaient prendre des émetteurs mais
je pense que giscard d'estaing l'aurait
fait c'était dans l'air du temps
effectivement françois mitterrand l'a
fait il était là au bon moment et avec
vision un petit peu plus gauche dans la
façon bien indiqué mais c'était pas
possible d'arrêter comme vous disiez pas
triste l'argument de la bande fm sa
durée alors qu'en fait on tournait son
bouton comme ça rien
donc voilà ça serait arrivé c'était dans
l'air du temps
d'ailleurs très souvent sur tous les
sujets les politiques souvent ne font
que que réagir après que l'évolution
soit faite et en matière de radio je
pense que c'est exactement la même chose
mais c'était un bon coup politique
mais ça vaut couper c'est la
récupération c'est un peu comme quand on
inaugure le tg le tgv croire c'est un
peu la même chose
la france choisit de guiraud comme quand
elle racontez nous un peu l'histoire
d'avant radio sensations et puis de
radio sensations quand on droit à mon
histoire et vaudois
moi j'ai découvert la radio relatif bon
tard j'étais très intéressé par la
télévision au départ je me souvenais
d'ailleurs j'avais souvent aux buttes
chaumont sur un plateau sur l'euphrate
excuses au 15 juillet un certain patrice
me semble-t-il de mardi
il est assez française c'était un vieux
magnifique où s'est passé beaucoup de
choses pour la télévision à l'époque
et donc c'était plus ce côté là qui me
fascinait j'ai découvert les radios fm
j'écoutais beaucoup des grandes ondes
vraiment notamment stl et j'écoutais peu
la fng pas vraiment vécu le début de la
bande fm avec la manifestation pour le
soutien énergique c'était à l'époque
j'ai découvert ça se rend chez moi près
de chez moi j'ai mon frère me dit tiens
je connais quelqu'un qui travaille dans
une radio je suis allé voir
puis effectivement ça a été pour moi la
révélation donc c'est après à partir de
86 87 je me suis vraiment intéressé à ce
média ce que faire d'un radio c'était
tellement facile effectivement faire de
la fm faut se rappeler qu'avant c'était
surtout les grandes ondes donc des
émetteurs surpuissante qui coûtait très
cher des antennes créer de son 150
mètres de haut qui étaient pour la
plupart donc situé au luxembourg en
allemagne ou en principauté de monaco
d'où le nom des radios périphériques à
l'époque et mais là et fait monter ce
qu'on appelle lundi polluantes n un
petit un petit boîtier qu'on allait
acheter en italie en général et puis ça
brûle en général tout le monde les
pompiers la télévision justement face à
un enfer pour n'importe quel monde
et puis au fur et à mesure c'était la
course à la puissance aussi acheter des
émetteurs de cuisine est de plus en plus
gros de plus en plus puissants donc mme
ouellet de la fm j'ai vécu un peu un peu
tardivement mais après c'est enfin
c'était effectivement un moment de
création enfin si on était tous est
devenue la règle
il faut se souvenir qu'à rtl et
europe 1 etc il était contre la fm a au
départ je disais non ça ne fonctionnera
jamais donc le la bande fm à l'époque
s'arrêter à 104 d'ailleurs je vous le
reste appartenait à l'armée
et quand ils sont rendus compte que la
fm notamment énergie avait énormément de
succès ils sont sur des côtés des le
grand soir des côtes et est meilleur
parce que les grandes zones s'était
enfin quand on réécoute les grands
besoins d'aujourd'hui il n'ya plus que
rtl qui aimait en 30 secondes
c'est à peu près historique le son était
très étouffé donc ils sont libres sont
quand même qu'on demande des fréquences
donc la bande fm a été élargie jusqu'à
108 létard et tripler si le sang 408
pour pouvoir notamment casey rtl europe
1 et c'est pour pour élargir la bande fm
donc les huiles et les radios
périphériques sont arrivés plutôt
tardivement
et puis c'était vraiment le la foire et
à l'époque on peut dire c'était au
premier qui émettrait j'ai vécu moi-même
saisie c'est très drôle oui on nous les
crs ont débarqué à la radio je me suis
enfermé dans la radio pour j'ai planqué
l'émetteur donc oui c'était tant que
c'était comme ça que ça se passait
ensuite ça s'est un peu plus régulé avec
tahri l'arrivée de la haute autorité au
départ la cncl ensuite
et puis le sait ça qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui vous parlez de carbone 14
c'était une des radios phare de la
libération vous propose d'écouter juste
un tout petit extrait avec avec le
célèbre la fesse
le podium ça ne soit pas si mal
et savait pas alors pédales
cemex à lui tout seul c'est beaucoup
plus courts des extraits de carbone 14
comme jeudi soir à l'actionnaire saison
parce qu'il a il invitait d'aider les
auditeurs à parler ils ont gueulé les
auditeurs fait cette semaine
alors il ya à la fois une liberté
absolue et puis si on regarde au fond
l'histoire de ces radios libres c'est
quoi c'est aujourd'hui énergie c'est fin
c'est des gros groupes profonde
inquiètude qui ont gagné non la radio
s'est standardisée il ya une aide
activement un emploi peu contraire mais
il ya aussi les on s'est standardisée
aussi dans d une radio associative
mais on sait aussi professionnaliser et
standardisée qui est fait au niveau
technique mais oui on va au bout d'un
certain temps c'était voilà celui qui
ferait le plus d'audience
nrj a apporté beaucoup de choses des
états unis de fabre las de haut niveau
de la programmation musicale avec
l'arrivée des panels pour pour le
l'arrivée le selector le logiciel de
programmation musicale donc petit à
petit et surtout avec l'arrivée de la
publicité
quant à publicité a été autorisée il y
avait un devoir
voilà de se professionnaliser pour être
crédible pour les annonceurs donc il y
avait deux camps les radios qui sont
vraiment professionnaliser les radios
qui ont voulu rester très indépendante
au niveau éditorial qui faisait un peu
tout et n'importe quoi pousser radio là
on finit un peu par à part disparaître
oui il y avait plus beaucoup et on
existe encore à quelques-unes sur paris
qui feront des émissions un peu hors du
temps ça existe je pense à la fréquence
paris plurielle par exemple qui qui est
toujours là donc il ya encore quelques
clés plus survivante eelv et ce n'est
pas demain soir il y avait aussi cette
dimension enfin 80 c'est vrai que les
grandes radios qui existe et c'était les
radios nationales sur lesquels le
pouvoir politique pouvait avoir une
influence y avait aussi cette cette
envie voilà de libération de liberté
c'est un certain point
extrêmement important parce que ce
véritable fleurissement s'était close
your c'est aussi l'instauration du
pluralisme du pluralisme politique qui
est qui et qui vraiment c'était pas nous
il ya cette époque francis guillot le le
le souligner tout à l'heure il ya eu il
y avait un contentieux d'ailleurs qu'on
suivait du côté du conseil d'état à
propos de d'une radio du parti
socialiste qui émettait clandestinement
qui saperait radio ici et maintenant
qu'ils installaient déplacer ces
émetteurs au jour le jour en fonction
des détections de la police est donc
cette explosion de du pluralisme a été
extrêmement sain pour la démocratie
cette liberté de parole alors qu'ils
allaient parfois très loin on a vu on a
aperçu jean yves lafesse tout à l'heure
moi je dépassais aussi le simple le
simple registre politique
je me souviens de revenir à carbone 14
des émissions justement avec avec jean
yves lafesse et supers nanas que dont
vous vous souvenez peut-être où je viens
j'écoutais ça alors c'était très drôle
c'était très amusant pour l'adolescente
gt mais on mesurait aussi où il y avait
aussi la première version de rfm avec
avec coluche qui tenait l'antenne
pendant des heures légales mais il y
avait une super sentiment de très très
grande liberté
durbin et à liberté qui qui s'ouvrait et
ça aussi vraiment une influence
considérable sur le sur le champ
politique sur le débat politique sur le
débat public
oui les réseaux liberté et libération
politique libération des moeurs aussi
avant le 16
géraldine chose qu'à l'europe ça reste
une voie mythique we dans les soirées de
géraldine je pense que tout le monde
s'en suivait un peu près est-ce que ça a
influé sur les sur les grandes radios
inter rtl europe
c'est cette liberté politiquement je
pense que je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya
plus haut il n'y a plus aucun pouvoir
politique qui oserait 10 à 40 ans je
vois mal brigitte lahaie sûr je crois
qu'elle est sur rtl ou sur eux
mais jeudi l'intrusion d'une ancienne
art 2 a donné dans une grande radio
voilà ceux d'il ya 40 ans s'était même
pas qu'on se valent maintenant moque
tout le monde dit oui c'est normal c'est
très bien pourquoi pas après le présume
pas de la qualité de son émission mais
en tout cas sa présence signifie bien
qu'il ya une celui d'une pénétration que
les traces optimiste en fait je suis
d'accord sur le fait qu'il ya eu cette
libération
et d'ailleurs il y avait un peu la même
tendance et vous y étiez à l'époque sur
la télévision je pense à apostrophes ou
autre aujourd'hui il ya plus ça va je
trouve qu'il ya plus ça on va pas me
sortira nous nommons comparer parce que
ça n'a rien à voir je trouve qu'il ya
moins ça en tout cas je trouve que les
radios sont normalisés et entre autres
je trouve que les extra dur périphérie
quand j'écoute j'entends rien de
révolutionnaire on est dans des choses
de qualité qui ressemble à ce qui se
faisait sur les grandes ondes avant moi
j'ai plutôt pessimiste j'ai l'impression
que cette éclosion extraordinaire
d'abord un effectivement par
l'obligation de se regrouper des radios
mais j'ai connu ça quand on nous a dit
radio scoop avait un côté catholique pas
du tout en plus un regroupez-vous et
radio notre dame
on s'était retrouvé reprise qui fait que
quand il y avait un chantre automatique
à 18 heures moi je faisais lui une
parade
et puis derrière on avait les chants
grégoriens et donc rien mais non mais
c'était original on a regroupé
puis la piste est arrivé c'est normal
fait beaucoup d'argent faire fonctionner
l'ensemble puis du coup on a normalisé
je trouve qu'aujourd'hui un cas est dans
une forme de normalité
par exemple je vois mal pour revenir à
télévision
mais ça relève pour moi la même
libération je vois mal le samedi à date
heure là la coco girl revenir web et
télévision quoi je suis un peu voilà
c'est à la fois musicale rent il a fait
disparaître
je suis jeune mais voilà mais méritoire
s'est posée par le non pas un hasard si
on parle plus de radios libres mais des
radios privées et c'est ça tout est dit
vous délivrent c'est vrai que le
marketing c'est aussi on parlait de ça
c'est par les radios musicales je savais
exactement quel morceau passé à quelle
heure etc
tout ça est assez aiguë en fin pas
règlementé mémé étudié en fin d'année
leçons sont arrivés voilà pour tester
les disques que l'on reçoit ou pour se
lever auprès d'un panel pour savoir quoi
passer à l'antenne
beaucoup de radios l'utilisent
aujourd'hui nous sur sensation
l'utilisent absolument pas nous c'est au
feeling encore c'est l'ancienne mais oui
malheureusement mais l'industrie du
disque aussi s'est standardisée quand on
voit tout ce qu'on reçoit clairement
enfin c'est du pareil au même parfois
ils sont des copier coller de d'autres
titres donc la liberté oui ça a été une
grosse effervescence dans les années 80
ça c'est forcément dissiper où il ya des
choses qu'on entendrait plus aujourd'hui
même a posteriori coluche aujourd'hui il
refait ses sketches
ou ses émissions sur une radio se ferait
démolir la série donne elle aurait été
viré oui c'est vrai il existerait
collaro show la face et collaro show
c'est qu'on n'aura pas ça ça serait
visible aujourd'hui aussi le soubresaut
vix danse à lire durant tour on ne
pouvait plus montré les coco girl s'est
terminée jeudi
c'est pas nous a l'impression qu'on a
perdu un peu de liberté justement
oui oui on a oui oui je suis d'accord il
ya une une espèce de de normalisation
mais mais c'est à l'image de la société
je pense la radio c'est l'une des images
l'un des reflets de la société mais ce
qui compte ce qui compte c'est que le
qui est quand même un socle un socle
pluraliste qui puisse continuer
continuer à exister même s'il ya un peu
moins de c'est un peu moins de relief
il faut quand même que le pluralisme
puisse continuer à s'exprimer
c'est que les fréquences ne nous
appartiennent pas elles appartiennent
toujours à l'état l'état nous donne une
concession pour 5 10 ou 15 ans et
sensations aujourd'hui yvelines sont
autorisations de fréquences arrive à
échéance à la fin d'année on doit
représenter un dossier a refait un appel
à candidatures donc l'état est toujours
propriétaire du parc de fréquences en
france donc voilà on a des comptes
rendus à fournir chaque année on doit
conserver nos enregistrements pendant un
mois minimum
parce qu'il peut y avoir un contrôle sur
sur les quotas de chanson française qui
nous ont été imposés dans les années 90
ça a été aussi un changement important
puisque alors nous importe est de
diffuser 40 % de chansons françaises
minimale que jamal c'est que vous avez
pas imposer des les horaires de passage
parce qu'on constate quand même que les
la chanson française c'est souvent de 2
heures du matin à 3/4 noir non parce que
les partis sont peut-être les quotas
sont comptabilisés de 6h30 à 22h30
leur truc c'est très tard la chanson
mais au souvent effectivement les radios
ont tendance à médecin après 20h alors
autour des quotas comme on dit non non
c'est un saint à la limite un peu oui
c'est osk et une fois de plus fins et un
peu côté pervers du système le csssae
s'y trouvent et mécanique pour pour
changer de fin pour trouver une solution
c'est qu'on m'avait toujours le même
artiste
vous aviez l'artiste était diffusé dix
vingt trente fois par jour c'était
infernal donc le panel d'artistes
s'était réduit mais aussi parce que
l'industrie musicale nous envoie peu de
chose enfin de manière générale il faut
aller les chercher
quand on a des eaux chi sur saint
quentin en yvelines que l'on découvre
c'est tout bénef pour nous on est très
content mais aujourd'hui enfin au niveau
du panel musical c'est quand même très
compliqué il à la radio fait encore le
succès des chanteuses oui je me rappelle
d'une anecdote par rapport aux énergies
justement où madonna avait refusé de
revenir sur des nrj music awards et à
l'époque max guazzini avait donc dix et
vingt puisque c'est comme ça on l'a
programme plus sur énergie et ça avait
fait quand même chuter les banques donc
oui oui oui les réseaux d les radios
sont encore prescriptive prescriptrices
pardon de en matière de programmation
musicale puisque la radio reste le média
préféré des français ça reste très
limité même si l'audience générale est
en baisse mais ça reste quand même très
très écouté vous avez raison de le dire
c'est le le méga dans lequel les
français ont le plus confiance
cette conquête le confirme alors pas des
jeunes les jeunes c'est vrai pour la b
c'est de dire que c'est aussi un média
qui attendront le public a tendance un
peu avis un oui complètement les jeunes
aujourd'hui vous écoute beaucoup moins
la radio c'est essentiellement les
réseaux sociaux ce sont les plateformes
de streaming qui qui sont utilisés les
jeunes écoutent beaucoup moins la rade
loire pour la musique pourquoi pas pour
l'information c'est plus gênant parce
qu'effectivement la crédibilité de
l'info soit réseaux sociaux là c'est un
problème donc les jeunes on écoute
beaucoup moins radio aujourd'hui et
regarde peu la tv aussi au nouveau
l'avenir de la radio vous le voyez
comment il faut savoir se renouveler je
pense que c'est le contenu la musique ne
fera plus la radio aujourd'hui pas
essentiellement fin pas claude à musique
les contenus locaux et surtout nous en
tant que radio locale on a un véritable
véritablement un atout c'est d'informer
les gens quotidien sur ce qui se passe
dans votre dans votre région comme le
fait tv 78 au niveau local pour la
télévision
ce qu'on sait ce qui se passe vraiment
le bout du monde mais finalement près de
chez nous on sait plus que moi donc les
gens reviennent vraiment à ça les
locales de france bleu de radio france
fonctionne très bien dans beaucoup de
régions
c'est pas pour rien parce qu'il ya une
vraie proximité donc faut réintroduire
de la proximité de la voie de
l'information et c'est ça l'avenir de la
radio et l'agenda radio c'est évidemment
le des abbés plus la radio terrestre
un changement est éteinte caste plus les
podcasts on en fait plus très longtemps
à internet
aussi nous l'audience numérique a
explosé à la faveur du confinement
on s'en est rendu compte donc ça va être
un petit peu un mix de tout ça voilà
internet le des abeilles l'afm encore
qu'il ya quelques années il ya la radio
on parle beaucoup de musique mais c'est
aussi la culture ce n'est pas que les
infos ou de la musique c'est de la
culture je veux dire france culture me
paraît une chaîne extraordinaire qui
continue à bien fonctionner il ya dix
nourrit de financement par le tas de
choses et on découvre des choses à la
radio que on ne ferait peut-être pas ce
choix à la télévision d'euros ça va être
en même temps alors qu'à la radio tout
eu tôt fait de capter et je ne suis pas
mal d'infos c'était absolument saisi il
ya un feuilleton sur france culture sur
sur flaubert mais c'est absolument
passionnant
par tranche de vingt minutes on est
scotché le truc on n'a pas envie d'arrêt
d'arrivée on veut écouter c'est fabuleux
d'avoir ça à l'heure actuelle bien un
feuilleton sur ce réseau des additions
par exemple parce qu'il a plus de france
inter c'est juste extraordinaire sur des
missions de référence il faut pas
oublier que la radio tout début c'était
essentiellement des fictions qui était
faite en direct avec des comédiens d'en
discuter
voilà les grands feuilletons la radio
dans ses débuts c'était vraiment
vraiment ça est hors service
allez on va passer peut-être on va
parler un petit peu de politiques tant
pis alors y'a rien
il ya une interview hier de jean luc
mélenchon alors qu'ils étaient assez
intéressante enfin parce qu'il rappelle
des faits qui ont existé pendant les
campagnes électorales
papy voise vous avez ce monsieur qui
avait été agressée en 2002 et dont on
dit que l'agression a fait monter
jean-marie le pen la ferme ra en 2012
l'attentât on essaie sur les
champs-elysées j'ai une semaine avant
les élections c'était pendant le débat
d'ailleurs je crois d des élections en
2010 est donc ces faits sont avérés
existants mais il a l'air d'en déduire
qu'il dit va se passer
aucune autre comme si tout ça était
prémédité quoi comme si ces attentats ou
c ou c ou c fait divers était prévu
d'avancé par qui on ne sait pas il ya
rien côté un petit peu complotistes dans
ce raisonnement vous l'avez entendu oui
j'ai entendu j'ai été très choqué alors
complotistes c'est évident je pense que
alors comme il est très intelligent je
pense pas que ce soit un dérapage
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant de voir
qu'il a fait la radio voix puisque je
l'aï bien que c'était surtout on
s'adresse autant sur le débat précédent
non mais ses propos sont à la fois
hallucinant d'abord hallucinant parce
que il laisse à penser que toutes ces
victimes qui sont quand même des
victimes du terrorisme de combat moi
c'est comme ça je les prix puisqu'il
permet d' incident il parle pas
d'assassinât il parle de meurtre où il
meurt d'une association de militer pour
protester j'ai même entendu la maman
d'un des militaires qui a été abattu par
mohamed merah effectivement monté au
créneau et elle a bien raison c'est
scandaleux
donc il ya sous cette partie là quand
même qui tend encore une fois quelque
part à gommer à normaliser à dire
qu'après tout c'est de son des
opérations de manipulation
et puis comment peut-on penser qu'il y
ait derrière cela une entité immanente
qui manipulerait des terroristes pour
faire des attentats dans le cadre de
d'élections mais enfin je veux dire
là il a perdu le sens des valeurs alors
je veux bien que monsieur mélenchon en
voyant tout le temps faire du buzz comme
on dit pour justement passé sur des
réseaux est d'ailleurs la preuve on en
parle aujourd'hui dont quelque part oui
donne raison mais en même temps on en
parle pour le condamner ce sont des
propos qui sont fous qu'ils sont fous
qui sont irrespectueux qui sont
choquants et moi si ma voix ne compte
pas bien entendu je le regrette mais moi
je l'appellerai ce qu'il revienne sur
ses propos ou moins ce qui l'est précise
plus tôt que ce que j'ai entendu
d'ailleurs dans les dernières 24 heures
ont gros comme d'habitude on nous fait
du rétropédalage en disant c'est
exactement ce qu'il a voulu dire non
c'est n'importe quoi c'est n'importe
quoi c'est scandaleux c'est choquant et
je trouve ça va de 20 mm relevés d'une
forme de condamnation
c'est bien évidemment choquant c'est
stupide c'est probablement complotistes
au delà de tout ça ce qui est
extrêmement inquiétant c'est la fin de
cette interview il parle de la
stigmatisation à venir du 2
les musulmans dire que lui on voit bien
que son combat c'est ça c'est d'essayer
de grappiller de faire venir à lui le
vote musulman s'ils tentaient que le
vote musulman existe bon on verra mais
en tout cas ça c'est sa tentative
une claire et nette donc donc c'est pas
il n'y a pas de quoi
crier au génie et puis après je pense
qu'il est à la limite de la folie parce
que il n'a toujours pas accepté
il n'a toujours pas accepté l'idée qu'il
avait perdu la dernière présidentielle
il est toujours là à parler des huit
cent mille voix d'écart mille huit cent
mille voix d'écart c'est énorme
il est 4e à la présidentielle au premier
tour 4e et 800 me et connaissez je ne
suis pas un fanatique de lionel jospin
lionel jospin il a perdu face à l'open y
avait deux cent mille deux cent
quatre-vingt dix minutes voix d'écart on
n'a jamais entendu jospin raleigh en dix
ans j'aurais dû être devant c'est un
scandale venons à 200 mille voix d'écart
il a accepté le jeu démocratique
n'existe pas il a quitté la vie
politique voilà c c ou non à quelque
chose qui l'honore mais mais mais mais
ce mélenchon qu'elle qui en permanence
dans dans la la récrimination disant
ouais mais huit cent mille voix à 1800
mhz et le voit c'est un scandale
ça donne l'impression pour exister il
faut toujours avoir la petite phrase de
saint tite chose qui va choquer qui va
provoquer et ensuite se faire passer
pour victime
je provoque que je me suis fait ensuite
passer pour victime pour cette
fonctionnement de jean luc mélenchon je
pense que je pense que ça étonne plus
personne aujourd'hui voilà c'est un peu
dommage puisque c'est la forme mais plus
le fond c'était vraiment un champ c'est
l'histoire d'un naufrage
c'est l'histoire d'une faillite alors
c'était pas 800 mille voix s'étaient
600000 mais c'est parce qu'il fait la
différence à 600 mille voix après
j'étais élu président de la république
en france et on résume les choses comme
ça est ce qui est complètement fou en
effet mais c'est pour moi oui l'histoire
d'un d'un grand naufrage mélenchon le
mélenchon dit ya une quinzaine d'années
était un fervent républicain
il portait au certaines des valeurs
fondamentales de la république
aujourd'hui il a totalement vrillé cc
c'est vraiment un
c'est vraiment un naufrage absolue est
de mon point de vue sur de nombreux
aspects aujourd'hui il se place vraiment
en marge de la république outre sujets
sur lesquels vous
interrogé on l'a vu enfin c'est la
réforme des retraites que reprend
emmanuel macron et on a l'impression que
il va essayer de jouer un coup c'est à
dire que de prendre un risque
ces 10 10 au fond je crois que l'analyse
est pas mauvaise on n'est jamais réunie
sur le propane risque risque absolu il
va peut-être prendre le risque de mettre
des gens dans la rue d'avoir les
syndicats contre lui mais de montrer
qu'au fond il fait des réformes jusqu'au
bout vous pensez que cette stratégie là
donc il est en train de jouer alors je
ne sais pas si c'est cette stratégie
néanmoins il demeure le fait que des
réformes des retraites s'impose en
france puisqu'on avait alors que camélia
selon lequel tout le monde est d'accord
mais il va très probablement des
mouvements sociaux dont la rue c'est
faire patrice convié d'accord tout le
monde est d'accord sur le fait qu'il
faut faire elle comme à laquelle
seraient d'accord sur la façon de la
faire donc effectivement sait toujours
pas si on a juste des critères ou si on
met dans l'ensemble justin bartha pour
reconstruire chose après qu'ils aient un
calcul politicien derrière tout ça a
certainement parce que nous sommes en
pré élection on est déjà dans l'après
dans la précampagne électorale
il ya aussi la réalité de voir le
calendrier parlementaire et quand on le
regarde on se rend compte qu'il ne voit
pas très bien comment on place une
réforme des retraites afin du
parlementaire c'est qu'il n'y a plus
place à côté ça c'est autre chose mais
qu'elle soit annoncé qu'elles soient
alors c'est intéressant de savoir qu'on
lance sur une réforme ne sera pas votée
bombés et leurs 3 je vous rejoins on
retombe dans une généralisation qui
veulent se faire réélire pendant la
dernière année il faut plus rien
waouh général ils font plutôt des
cadeaux non c'est assez compliqué mais
en même temps peut-être que ça peut
permettre de pourquoi pas faire basculer
parce que s'il a essayé pour le risque
pourrait essayer ou après tout ça serait
le premier président réélu monthey n'a
en tous cas mais je voudrais pas qu'on
doive à moi ce que je voudrais
simplement dire que je veux pas qu'on
veut comme la nécessité de la réforme et
que du coup parce qu'effectivement ça
mais voilà je dis oui il faut faire une
réforme des retraites en france
il faut se le dire donc après que ce
soit à l'occasion effectivement d'une
réélection ce soit à l'occasion de la
première année d'un nouveau quinquennat
dans tous les cas de figure il faut
refaire le système peut-être que par
exemple une façon de faire la réforme
des retraites plutôt que d'aller
rallonger la durée de cotisation montant
des cotisations ou de fans de retraite
par points s'est peut-être de revenir
sur les 35 heures on peut aussi
travailler plus d'une autre manière en
travaillant plus longtemps
par exemple chaque semaine il ya
plusieurs pistes qui permettrait aussi
de récupérer effectivement ces bandes de
cotisation pourquoi pas stéphane bancel
pour être élu il faut prendre des
risques
oui oui je pense qu'il faut prendre des
risques et je pense que le président de
la république actuel a montré qu'il
qu'il prenait des risques qu'il
n'hésitait pas à prendre des risques ce
qui pour le moins tranche avec ses c'est
cesser ses prédécesseurs les du moins
des trois précédents et d'autre part si
réforme des retraites il y a de nouveau
ce sera pas la même ce sera pas la même
réforme déjà le message commence à
comment ça a passé
donc je moment je suis convaincu que
dans les dix mois qui viennent dd cette
réforme là est peut-être pas seulement
seront remises remise sur le métier ça
j'en suis j'en suis absolument convaincu
le dernier sujet parce que c'est une une
qui m'a amusé c'est celle de marianne
sur sur le l'esprit de sérieux qui peut
être nous
nous enferme alors ouais ils n'ont pas
mal de se prendre au sérieux c'est vrai
que j'ai l'impression qu'à chaque fois
que quelqu'un bigard dit des choses
absolument insensé on est là a commenté
à dire les expliciter vous pourrez dire
on va cesser nul et puis voilà vous avez
tout à fait raison
après ski et le problématique c'est de
faire la liste des gens pas crédible et
inintéressant de bigard de lalanne de
pascal praud de de villiers
c'est vrai que le bouquin de villiers
c'est quand même assez incroyable il dit
voilà il ya un complot qui a qui a lancé
le virus pour établir un gouvernement
mondial
un bouquin qu'ils vont à des millions
d'examens de milliers d'exemplaires on
ne peut pas non plus de traiter sous
silence ça veut dire qu'il a quand même
trouvé son public et moi j'ai pas lu le
livre était a priori un peu
abracadabrantesque mais on peut pas
balayer comme sa der veer demande ça
nous plaît pas et c'est comme pascal
praud c'est qu'il est très très chic de
dire que c'est pas bien
des millions de gens qui m'écoutent tous
les jours y en a un petit peu plus lent
fin tout cas c'est vraiment une émission
qui compte monde ival des hommes
politiques commencent à s'y précipiter
et donc mais comme ça plaît pas au melia
principaux dia ba oui alors celui c'est
un clown mais il ya quand même rien en
commun entre pascal praud et bigard ni
entre hanouna et eric zemmour enfin le
voilà donc si je suis pas d'accord avec
cette liste il ya des gens comprennent
que l'on oui mais voilà les blessés sur
des cas différents voilà même essence
allant de 1 à nouer et francis la
question c'est parce que c'est pas le
sérieux serre que c'était la mythomanie
et le et le discours péremptoire terre
que jasseines des vérités avec un b
majuscule que je ne prends pas la peine
de démontrer et d'autre part je suis
hermétique à toute contradiction
donc on peut aller très loin et en effet
alors très bien s'est regardé ou écouté
par des millions de personnes mais ça on
est on est ici dans la quantité ont
rejoint ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
ce qui n'est pas synonyme de vérité
c'est tout donc c'est un côté
complètement fou c'est un côté
risqué aussi pour le débat public pour
la démocratie puisque toutes les paroles
se valent manifestement et que d'autre
part et c'est ce qu'on a vu au cours de
la cour des mois et de l'année qui vient
de s'écouler
c'est que de toute façon l'argument
l'argument d'autorité l'argument de de
celui qui a passé des années et des
années à travailler sur une question ne
vaut pas mieux ne vaut pas plus que les
éructations d'un de du premier venu
voilà donc ça c'est enfin c'est à la
fois complètement dingue de mon point de
vue extrêmement grave
oui c'est vrai que toutes les opinions
se valent c'est un oui c'est vrai mais
après si on donne parfois trop
d'importance à des choses qui ne m'ont
pas c'est aussi le travers des réseaux
sociaux où ça sur réagit à la moindre
petite phrase au moindre petit monde
donc enfin voilà faut il ya un moment
faut garder cela ne peut-être normal
après tout deux voilà de donner un peu
de distance non à tout et c'est automne
et degré mt nous c'est un peu le
problème selon lequel des revenus
journal absolument vintage jaffa le truc
c'est démodé au delà du week end
graphiquement c'est terrible non non non
vous aimez travailler en jean françois
cabanât oui mais je partage assez le
fait que la liste un peu la prévert et
comme ceux qui s'y rendre ça fait la
diffusion dans une poupée après
j'entends tout à fait ce que disait
stéphane mention sur le fait qu'il faut
démontrer effectivement les propos quand
on entend quand on les fait en même
temps sept sont des polémistes donc sa
partie au fait qu'il nous fallait
démontrer et en plus il ya toujours un
peu un côté paris-province aussi parce
que proulx c'est un peu la parole du
territoire un peu simple mais c'est
aussi des gens qui existe et puis enfin
je finirai sur le fait que marianne se
prend pas et ne se prennent pas le même
sérieux puisque la minute où je vois les
carottes crie-t-elle quand on les
arrache
diack marianne dans la même catégorie
quelque part j'avais un autre débat mais
on n'a plus le temps qui était essentiel
quand même qu'ils étaient dans le figaro
pour ou contre la chemisette vous
propose d'en parler à notre église
merci infiniment à tous les cas merci
stéphane michaud francis migros merci
vous êtes ici chez vous à 8 heures les
surveillants
vous connaissez la maison merci laurent
mazaury et j'espère déjà dit à très vite
pour un nouveau numéro de parfum
[Musique]